es una muestra significativa de
solidaridad en el país patriarcal que ha
sido sacudido por una serie de protestas
contra el gobierno los hombres salen a
las calles de Irán en apoyo a las
mujeres que se manifiestan después de
que maxsamini de 22 años fuera asesinada
bajo la custodia de la policía de la
moral del país el 16 de septiembre su
primo dice que su muerte ha abierto Las
puertas a un malestar generalizado
lo que está ocurriendo en el kurdistán y
en todo Irán es la ira universal contra
el régimen de la República islámica
contra La dictadura la muerte de amini
desencadenó la mayor oleada de ira
contra el sistema gobernante en Irán más
de una década las mujeres iraníes
corearon muerte al dictador pidieron el
fin del régimen ultraconservador de la
República islámica sin embargo algunos
hombres se niegan a concebir su país
como uno en el que las mujeres no están
en segundo plano Respecto a los hombres
soy un hombre que ha nacido y se ha
criado en un país del Tercer mundo mis
reivindicaciones pueden ir en sentido
contrario a las demandas de las mujeres
no soy tan abierto de mente pero las
mujeres como individuos tienen sus
propios derechos sus demandas y lo están
pidiendo
se ha celebrado concentraciones
progubernamentales en varias ciudades de
Irán algunas personas pidieron una
respuesta decisiva a los manifestantes
por parte del sistema gobernante del
país el presidente de Irán advierte que
no aceptará el caos en la nación